when i've listened to you and i've
watched the show it feels like
uh one of the things that i never did
this successfully i never had beef with
anybody
i know and i always felt like um that's
kind of
something that that some people are very
good at and then
uh i remembered once it wasn't that long
ago but you guys had beef
but it didn't feel like it was worthy of
you because it was with jaleel white
and i felt like the things that are
flawed and i'm
i swear to god you guys don't need my
help you need nothing from me but i'm
just going to offer constructive
criticism
a better origin story i like the new one
you've come up with you didn't meet
in summer school you met when you both
killed an old woman accidentally
and you buried her upstate b i love the
beef thing you've got to have but
it can't be jaleel white you've got to
step it up a notch it's got to be bigger
than that
technically we have beef with obama he
came in hot talking spicy about our
knicks and you know
like there's only but so much beef you
can have with a former president he
could get to do drone strikes
he could have served so you know it's
not we're still trying to work it out
but i think
obama's that's people a good guy that's
a good guy to have beef with i've
noticed
he likes to talk smack that guy he likes
to i was like
i was uh years ago when i did uh
white house correspondents dinner i i'm
there and he's in a line greeting people
before the dinner and he's greeting
people and my brother had come down
my brother and his wife uh justin and
joanna
and they're they go up and they're
taking a picture with uh the president
and the first lady
and all of a sudden i hear obama i'm
standing in the corner
not taking a picture because i you know
i'm worried about my set
and here coming coming and i look over
and it's president obama and he says
your brother
much better looking than you see
what the [ __ ] did i do i'm just in the
corner
minding my own business shots fired yeah
exactly and i thought
he had to seek me out in the room to
[ __ ] on me
and uh he is he's that guy he's that guy
he is that guy he knows what movie is
that with the sniper it would like
it's like uh jude law plays a snipe
behind enemy lines oh yeah
enemy at the gates enemy at the gates he
just interviewed the gates with you bruh
yeah yeah i would have went with an
american sniper reference there but you
know enemies
says i'm with you
deep cuts with snarks behind the gates
whatever the [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's your guy matt remembers
everything
obama's like the roommate that slowly
kills you using eye drops where you're
not watching
like you don't see what he's doing but
he gets you
yes he tricks you because he's got this
i don't know i noticed it because uh we
talked to him a couple weeks ago and
he's just
he's got this walk he's got this very
chill
walk and he says it's and he chill he he
fools you
with this i'm a regular i'm a guy from
hawaii
i don't get that worked up about stuff
i'm no drama obama
i'm just and so you're not expecting it
and also
he's a man that has had to contemplate
real problems and had the nuclear codes
so you think there's no
way he's going to take the time make me
look like a fool
and then he does yeah he's got time he's
got time
now have you seen have you seen this
book it's 80 000 pages
yes and the best part of obama is he
he does he comes off like you say he
comes off so cool you're like oh he's
former president he's so cool
he would probably have that same level
of coolness if he was just like
your aunt's unemployed husband that you
know yeah sometimes stole some stuff but
you'd be like
i hate barry but you know what he's a
good guy ah
he's a good guy barry's a kind of a wild
guy but he's you know he's the number
one real estate agent
or it annoys me that barry doesn't get a
job and he's hangs he sleeps on the
couch
and he doesn't contribute to the rent
but he's a cool guy he's a cool guy
yeah he's chill he comes through a weed
sometimes
well he's just like hey he's like conan
you're hungry they were having
two-for-one whoppers at burger king
you're like oh
oh thank you guys all right thank you so
much that was so nice of you